nella puntata precedente porca vacca che
kakà dobbiamo andarcene che cosa che non
va con te porca vacca gwh a salve a
tutti i ragazzi ebbene questo video sono
fa vj io ci siamo dati su vignette che
un bel nome insomma per gioco di demoni
nelle case abbandonate vabbè lasciamo
perdere vi lascio al video buona visione
ho aperto non aver fatto vedo che tutto
allego in sta a casa poi smetterà di
avere la l'iniziato né per cortesia
grazie per cosa qua il libro blu ho
trovato lì ho trovato un libro blu mi
serviva questo possiamo entrare senza
aver paura che con la miss alti in bocca
da un momento all'altro perfetto ha
chiuso la porta proprio il buco è
veramente piccolo in che senso
e devo trovare la chiave per aprire la
porta forse devo inserire il libro in un
punto preciso e mi dà la chiave non lo
so lo trovate a chiave in poche parole
ha già che c'erano stato qualche poté
rischia sempre non avrebbe capito e per
spegnere il camino porca vacca abbia
visto elettorato indietro che culo che
culo era tornare dietro perfetto ospiti
mi sa che mi ha sentito non mi sta più
seguendo ma secondo me non sono tanto
sicuro non possono anche nascondermi
tipo in aoni poi buttati giù per favore
poi buttarti giù di nuovo mai fatto
prima non puoi farlo credo di aver
spinto il cammino con quel posto lì
giusto cioè servirà qualcosa ve la passo
senza hanno un aspetto generale ciani
immagine la fiamma
porca vacca non ha spento il camino a me
la sono beccata davanti pure dov'è
andata c'è stata tanta gente di mare
nella cella ce la si può uscire
sono uscito a posto il gioco completo
finito va bene così la tavola degli
spiriti di felice cioè praticamente
felice era venuta qua e noi l'abbiamo
accompagnata perché le piaceva fare la
tavola uri già dei deficienti non poteva
stare a casa a guardare i video di
qualcosa di youtube
no lava fa la tavola dice vabbè brava
complimenti non so dove sia finita però
spendiamo suo fuoco vi prego no facciamo
una stampa che figo che figata
no questo successo a ciò che è stato
io non ho fatto niente mi dispiace non
volevo questo combinato un casino è
cascato coso lì c'è una bambola che si
siede su una sedia perfetto bottiglie ci
sono dei simboli qua sembra che ne
manchino alcune dove sono andate
veramente le devo trovare dove infilare
lì
ottimo invece di prendersi quelle che ci
sono la mettiamo le altre regaliamo loro
alla gente vabbè messo quella roba lì se
si muove faccio un salto di un metro
quindi andiamo di qua regala però mi è
il posto più strano che abbia mai visto
ma ce la fate potete non mettere una
bambola ogni tre metri per cortesia sono
molto carine per carità però vedo gente
ferma prima o poi qualcuno si muove io
lo so io lo so ho giocato a troppi
giochi perché so benissimo questa cosa
buongiorno a lei se in touch e gente
ferma qua si afferma anche lei per
cortesia messo cosa che questo suo cuore
raga questo horror e orribile orribile
sento cose orribile via via via via via
orribile orribile mi mettono gli effetti
sono i dove non devono metterli via via
via velocissimi sapevo che prima o poi
aveva risentito una porta o robe del
genere è un'atmosfera incredibile via
via via fuori proprio fuori come se non
ci fosse tutto moro land vai vai salva
la partita pure che ha senso rumori
strani molto bene andiamo ad aprire la
baracca vediamo cosa ci trovi dentro
effetto molto bene
wood en plein amia davis ottenuto
proprio le travi non si butta via niente
qua potete sono venuto qua dentro per
prendermi the wooden blanks qua credo
che non sia per questo me ne faccio
delle v the plains vabbè andiamo a
passare al buco quello gigantesco che
c'era almeno con le travi riesco sempre
molto tranquillo entrare nella bocca di
un camino a forma di demonio tra l'altro
quando ho sentito prima rumorino tutto
molto bello permesso semi saltate
addosso io vi ammazzo non mi non non non
mi toccare b b a b picchio tutti credo
che mi scusi io volevo mettere le travi
però te ne devi andare sono chiede
traviss amy chiarimento a fare ma
scrivere e facciamo che non le metto più
vado via
adesso io rientro eccola lì deve essere
sparita dalla mia vita ok essere sparita
va bene perché la mia vita è fatta di
ansie andato via
sai che ti dico in groppa t te io te le
mettono 6 passa passa e scappa 4 cosa
come alle insieme è una gara che mi
seguivamo e che voglio io ho servito la
strada scappa l'abbia massei che dovete
controllare se questi si muovono non si
muovono e che è un'ottima notizia
questa porta
[Musica]
ho un biliardo allegro almeno quello
salve c'è un tiro a segno
wow ma che figo la stanza di giò sono i
così d'oro prendi li prendi li prendi
possono essere spostati giuste che non
mi ricordo quali quali c'erano e quali
no vado a vedere nel mentre che non mi
succede niente o allegra anche questa
stanza meno male che un gioco allegro
finalmente lo spirito natalizio che che
che sorge molto contento sono salve lei
è jason di vera di te se mi tocca la de
nunzio cosa serve stanza solo un coso
dove fidarci una chiave dentro che non
ho quindi avrà la porta questo non mi
sembra neanche lei è bello suo bagno
sono più sporco di prima entrando qua
dentro no vabbè c'è un liquido rosso si
chiama sangue non fa niente c'è niente
nel bagno cosa sarà questo bagno ma c'è
un'altra porta con sé tante porte
nato a bagno con le con le tende chiuse
tra l'altro questo
[Musica]
pensavo peggio
secchio no veramente ho riempito il
secchio di sta roba ma che schifo
cosa ti serve un secchio per caso non è
che lo devo ammettere di là del momento
no di qua non riempire questa vasca sex
cosa c'é qua sotto niente è
completamente vuota adesso a cosa è
servito spiegano o c'era una zia che non
ho ben capito cosa però c'era una tipa
va bene abbiamo finito però dovete stare
calmi tutti che vi ammazzo questo lo
dovete capire trovato un pezzo di di
scacchi pietro il cui il vetro bene
c'era anche satana tra l'altro che però
va bene tutto sto casino per un pezzo
degli scacchi senza te c'è uno squalo
però vabbè ho tratto un libro verde sul
libro verde ma ciò se al libro blu del
libro verde ok ma vedi ci stavano i
simboli perché mi faccia voto sta cosa
che non si sa mai
ok e poi vi ricordate che c'erano i cosi
loro che erano tipo qui eccoli ecco mi
devo ricordare questi spetta che
facciamo dovrà questi e modo devo
toccare quelli giusti visto grandi sotto
mi ricordo stavano quando ho allora e
cosi sono l'ancora timone la clessidra
il granchio il quella roba lì lo
schiacciare quelli che mancavano
schiacciamo di che mancavano si è
sbloccato qualcosa cosa sbloccato una
chiave
greco ho trovata la chiave greco o
grazie della greca erano sei anni che
volevo trovare a stare bene ma che ciò
il greco entro ovunque con greco la
regola fare qualsiasi cosa prendi tutto
questa al pianoforte che sono tra
l'altro telecom aia prima felice a noi
più uccidermi thyssen e staff a
beethoven meno male perché se non era un
problema era la tua melodia preferita
quando le nostre fiamme dell'amore erano
ancora vive smettila felice tutto quel
che dici non ha senso e xing hazard ma
ritorna che il coltello
mi odi veramente mi odi non c'è modo di
tornare indietro adesso cipro stai calma
non capisco che cosa sta succedendo ma
ti prometto che ti aiuterò felice se
messa di suonare di nuovo va bene
tratto dei film lei sta lì a so adesso
suona s'è messo a suonare vabbè sta
suonando con la testa sul pianoforte tra
l'altro così c'è lei suona così
pianoforte e vabbè c'è la sequenza a
tenere ok che tipo di frequenza in una
sequenza randomica devo trovare un modo
comunque l'altra stata lo devo
sicuramente vedere cosa c'é nell'altra
statua a 12 13 a 13 2 1 3 2 1 3 2 4 5 6
1 3 2 4 5 6 1 3 2 4 5 6 1 2 4 5 6 motore
da qualcuno l'esca a comportamento open
land indizi bass e vabbè che casino è
successo un pezzo di scacchi va bene ho
aperto una stanza non ho capito bene
cosa hanno aperto va bene che i ragazzi
continuano nel prossimo non so se siamo
vicini alla fine probabilmente sì ma
spero vi stia piacendo
come siete ragazzi se vi è piaciuto non
commento mi piace anche vari soci alcuna
descrizione se rischiate v
noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vita da
ragazzi
[Musica]
ma